[Musik]
sorge vor radikalisierung rechtsextreme
und verschwörungstheoretiker
unterwandern demos gegen korona
beschränkungen endlich wieder offen in
immer mehr bundesländern ist der besuch
von gaststätten wieder erlaubt wenn auch
mit einschränkungen und leichte
lockerungen in frankreich nach acht
wochen dürfen die menschen wieder ihre
häuser verlassen ohne einen grund
nachzuweisen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem 11 schön dass sie dabei sind
es sind insgesamt bislang nur einige
tausend bürger die hierzulande gegen die
korona beschränkungen auf die straße
gehen trotzdem beobachten viele die
bundesweiten proteste mit sorge nicht
nur weil dort zum teil abstandsregeln
missachtet werden
auch weil rechte gruppen und
verschwörungstheoretiker versuchen die
demos zu vereinnahmen und die
gesellschaft zu spalten kann hier
punkten berichtet proteste gab es am
wochenende in vielen deutschen städten
und in vielen sehr unterschiedlichen
schattierungen
wir sind heute schon zum zweiten mal als
familie und der hauptgrund ist einfach
der dass die maßnahme unserer meinung
nach einfach weit überzogen sind
wo viele ihr grundrecht auf
demonstrationsfreiheit nutzen etwa gegen
die einschränkungen andere grundrechte
mischen sich unterschiedlichste andere
strömungen in den protest mal geht es
kategorisch gegen das impfen mal gegen
einzelpersonen wie bill gates oft um
rang von weltumspannenden
verschwörungstheorien ausgehend von
gruppen die diese schon zuvor
verbreiteten und kommunen nun nutzen so
das bka jetzt wird wieder aufkommenden
demonstrationen sehen wir das ist vor
allem versucht wird gerade aus dem
rechten spektrum proteste aus dem
bürgerlichen lager die es aber auch
dagegen gestimmt sind dass sie natürlich
von dem crawler maßnahmen belastet sind
zu kapern sondern es jetzt mal um dort
auch ihre weltanschauung und theorien zu
verbreiten
die polarisierung droht zunehmend auch
die gesellschaftliche mitte zu erfassen
zwischen jenen die die einschränkung
maßnahmen kritisch sehen und gehen die
die proteste dagegen kritisch sehen
beides müsse möglich sein so heute der
tenor in berlin
dabei ist abstand zu halten von
jeglichen gegnern unserer freiheitlichen
demokratie von allen obskuren
verschwörungstheoretikern das galt vor
corona und auch weiterhin
insofern muss die politische debatte
über aufklärung dazu beitragen dass
diese
verschwörungstheoretiker und teilweise
sehr völkischen anti staatlichen
antidemokratischen tendenzen aus diesen
demonstrationen möglichst ferngehalten
werden
eine diffizile aufgabe die die korona
politik ab jetzt begleitet theo koll in
berlin wie ernst nimmt die regierung
diese proteste ich glaube sind das sehr
ernsten die demonstrationen gegen die
krone regeln beinhalten ja eine art
doppelte distanz dilemma einerseits
versammeln sich tausende ohne schutz und
abstandsregeln einzuhalten und damit
besteht ein hohes biologisches
ansteckungsrisiko und dazu kommt eine
art politisches ansteckungsrisiko also
corona müde bürger treffen auf ein
gemisch aus verschwörungstheoretikern
impfgegnern und extremisten
verschiedensten schattierungen alles
offenbar auch noch angefeuert durch
russische bots also computerprogramme
die kanzlerin
so wurde uns berichtet hat jedenfalls
heute morgen im cdu präsidium
ausdrücklich auf diese russischen
propaganda quellen hingewiesen und viele
in berlin werden noch die pedale
erfahrung im hinterkopf haben
auch das wird nicht zur beruhigung
beitragen auch wenn es sich bisher bei
den corona protesten jahr um eine eher
kleine minderheit handelt die
einschätzung unseres berlin
korrespondenten vielen dank grundlage
für entscheidungen der politik sind
verschiedene zahlen unter anderem die
reproduktionsrate die liegt nach
schätzung des robert koch instituts
weiter über der kritischen schwelle von
1 bei 1,13 heißt jeder infizierte steckt
im schnitt mehr als eine weitere person
an folgen der aktuellen lockerungen
lassen sich daran allerdings nicht
ablesen denn die produktionszahl zeigt
die situation von vor einigen tagen
dazwischen infektionen meldungen und
befragungen der betroffenen zeit vergeht
der trend bei den täglichen
neuansteckungen ist fallend im
durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
waren es täglich 890 insgesamt wurden
laut johns hopkins universität 171 1999
infektionen durch tests bestätigt davon
gelten 145 1600 als genesen
7569 menschen sind in verbindung mit
coop 19 gestorben
zahlen die sowohl sorge als auch
zuversicht begründen können je nachdem
wie man sie interpretiert entscheidend
wird die entwicklung der nächsten tage
und wochen seien gerade jetzt wo immer
mehr bereiche des täglichen lebens
wieder anlaufen
was ich da mit dem heutigen tag ändert
zeigt volker dutschek training unter den
augen des ordnungsamtes in diesem kölner
fitnessstudio kamen bereits um
mitternacht dutzende die wochenlang auf
klimmzüge und co verzichten mussten
wenige kilometer entfernt die erste
tanzstunde koreanischer pop heute kein
paar tanz anfassen verboten masken
müssen nicht sein aber abstand halten
gemacht alles wurde geschlossen das
hätte wohl wir online unterricht hatten
in niedersachsen tag eins nach der
korona sperre in der gastronomie in der
gaststätte ständige vertretung wurde
acht wochen lang kein einziger kaffee
mehr ausgeschenkt das gaststättengewerbe
ist mit 1,5 millionen mitarbeitern ein
zentraler wirtschaftsfaktor mehr als
165.000 betriebe
der jahresumsatz liegt bei fast 51
milliarden euro
es werden keine einfachen zeiten
prophezeit der hotel und
gaststättenverband erfordert einen
staatlichen rettungsfonds sein
schreckensszenario ein drittel der
betriebe wird nicht überleben
ja es wird nicht einfacher aber trotzdem
freuen uns auf machen zu können überall
lockerung und trotzdem wird in berlin
ein corona not krankenhaus offiziell
eröffnet für viele mag das wie ein
widerspruch wirken aber der bau des
behandlungszentrums wurde vor vier
wochen geplant als niemand absehen
konnte wie sich die infektionszahlen
entwickeln werden
im fall der fälle könnten hier 500
patienten isoliert werden falls die
berliner kliniken im lauf der pandemie
an ihre grenzen stoßen auch online
bieten wir interessante informationen
wer wissen möchte wie das robert koch
institut arbeitet wer es finanziert und
welche
kick ass an seinem vorgehen gibt das
alles nachzulesen in unserer zdf heute
app nimmt in der korona krise
misshandlung und missbrauch von kindern
zu bislang gibt es dafür keine anzeichen
heißt es heute vom bundeskriminalamt das
könne aber auch daran liegen dass kinder
zurzeit weniger kontakt zu erziehern und
lehrern haben an die sie sich wenden
können
für 2009/10 zeigt die kriminalstatistik
die zahlen sind weiter alarmierend hoch
britta später spiekermann lüfte und
bergisch gladbach zwei orte diese
perfide netzwerke stehen kinder wurden
gequält wurden missbraucht die täter aus
allen gesellschaftlichen schichten
die kriminalstatistik schlägt alarm 112
kinder wurden 2009 10 getötet
vorsätzlich oder fahrlässig erschreckend
auch die zunahme von sexueller gewalt
besonders im netz im letzten jahr wurden
12.000 2 162 fälle von herstellung
verbreitung und besitz
kinderpornografischer schriften in der
polizeilichen statistik erfasst und das
entspricht einem zuwachs von 65 prozent
im vergleich zum vorjahr die zunahme
registrierter fälle erklärt sich auch
dadurch das personal aufgestockt wurde
verdeckt ermittelt wird täter kommen
aber oft davon bei provider gesetzliche
mindestspeicherfrist von ip adressen
nicht einhalten sich die spur dadurch
verliert auch jugendliche werden
zunehmend zu tätern
tausende bilder und videos in chats
geteilt experten sprechen von einer
vergifteten enthemmung auch sexueller
missbrauch ist eine pandemie und durch
die häusliche isolation sind viele
kinder in noch größerer gefahr vor
innerfamiliärer gewalt
es fehlt die soziale kontrolle durch
kindergärten und hilfseinrichtungen das
hinter verschlossenen türen und fenstern
geschieht ist ungewisser denn je
ganz anderes thema jetzt eine bewaffnete
drohnen fliegt ferngesteuert über ein
ziel weit entfernt geben soldaten den
tödlichen
feuerbefehl präzise und ohne gefahr für
die eigenen truppen
die usa bekämpfen so seit langem ihre
gegner
ob die bundeswehr ebenfalls kampfdrohnen
anschaffen soll ist umstritten auch aus
ethischen gründen das
verteidigungsministerium sagt ja jetzt
hat eine anhörung dazu begonnen aus
berlin cornelia schiemenz es war der 31
august 2009 10 im camp abm afghanischen
kundus schlagen fünf granaten abgefeuert
von taliban
von den rund 100 deutschen soldaten und
soldatinnen wird niemand verletzt aber
die angst bleibt die soldaten wünschen
sich mehr möglichkeiten sich selbst zu
verteidigen eine variante bewaffnete
drohnen für die bundeswehr wollen trum
zu unserer eigenen verteidigung und zu
unseren eigenen schutz einsetzen als die
verteidigungsministerin im dezember vor
ort ist zeigt sie sich offen für
bewaffnete drohnen bislang setzt die
bundeswehr in afghanistan und mali
insgesamt sechs drohnen des typs heron 1
die sind unbewaffnet und ausschließlich
zur aufklärung da die anschaffung so
genannter kampfdrohnen eine wichtige und
kontroverse debatte öffentlich gestartet
heute im verteidigungsministerium
der koalitionspartner spd gibt sich
zurückhaltend und das muss nicht nur
allgemein skizziert werden sondern das
muss auch niedergelegt werden und das
verteidigungsministerium würde gern die
drohne heron tp kaufen die kann man auch
bewaffnen
die opposition gespalten drohnen die
nicht bewaffnet sind wären die waffen
oder munition und wir sollten sie allein
deswegen bewaffnen um am langen ende
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten zu
schützen wir wollen das nicht und zwar
aus dem einfachen grund ist senkt die
hemmschwelle für militärische eingriffe
die debatte über bewaffnete drohnen ist
eröffnet vertreter des
globalisierungskritischen netzwerkes
attac haben heute schon mal gezeigt was
sie von den plänen halten nichts nach
syrien wo immer noch krieg herrscht und
amnesty international jetzt schwere
vorwürfe erhebt gegen die
regierungstruppen von machthaber assad
und ihre verbündeten aus russland beide
hätten
gezielt krankenhäuser und schulen
angegriffen zwischen mai 2009 10 und
februar 2020 hätten beide streitkräfte
mindestens 18 solcher angriffe verübt
zwei davon mit international geächteten
fast bomben amnesty stützt sich auf
interviews mit mehr als 70 personen
darunter augenzeugen ärzte und
vertrieben
zurück nach europa in frankreich gelten
sehr viel strengere corona auflagen als
bei uns seit heute aber dürfen die
franzosen nach 55 tagen ausgangssperre
wieder vor die tür und zwar ohne
passierschein auch die geschäfte öffnen
wieder und sport und spaziergänge sind
wieder uneingeschränkt erlaubt
geschlossen bleiben restaurants und bars
auch bei den franzosen ist die zahl der
registrierten neuinfektionen in den
letzten tagen zurückgegangen
aus paris berichtet christel hass
männern mit seltsamen gepäck stehen im
metro eingang sie gehören zu einem
besonderen einsatz kommando
sie verteilen desinfektions gel an die
passagiere auch masken gibt es heute
gratis in der u-bahn sind sie pflicht
genauso wie der sicherheitsabstand nur
jeder zweite platz darf benutzt werden
es ist ziemlich sonderbar aber wir
werden uns daran gewöhnen müssen
ich hatte ein paar vorbehalte aber es
sind nicht viele leute da also bin ich
beruhigt alles läuft gut frankreich ist
seit heute zweigeteilt grün heißt mehr
freiheiten roth dazu zählt paris heißt
unter anderem parks museen gymnasien
bleiben zu im ganzen land dürfen die
geschäfte öffnen schnell mal was kaufen
geht aber nicht nur tröpfchenweise
bekommen die kunden zutritt und überall
gilt sicherheit und schutz gehen vor nur
eine umkleidekabine sei offen erzählt
diese boutique besitzerin so dass
jeweils nur eine kundin etwas
anprobieren und sich anschauen könne
die geschäfte sind wieder offen man
braucht keinen passierschein mehr um vor
die tür zu gehen
das empfinden alle hier als große
erleichterung am tag eins der
lockerungen ist das befürchtete chaos
vor allem im nahverkehr ausgeblieben
viele sind noch vorsichtig und sagen
sich wohl nach 55 tagen ausgangssperre
kommt es auch den ein oder anderen
tag mehr nicht mehr an denn auch wenn
sich alle über die neuen freiheiten
freuen
die angst vor einer zweiten welle und
den folgen ist groß wenn das virus sich
wieder unbändig ausbreitet und eine
gefahr für die gesundheit darstellt dann
müssen wir das öffentliche leben wieder
einschränken japan wo die musik kino
es ist eine herausforderung auch für
emanuel makro es geht um die
glaubwürdigkeit seiner politik denn nur
noch 40 prozent der franzosen vertrauen
ihrem präsidenten
auch in spanien gibt es weitere
lockerungen allerdings nur für gut die
hälfte der einwohner in vielen regionen
dürfen bars und restaurants im
außenbereich wieder öffnen bis zu zehn
personen können sich wieder treffen in
denen von corona besonders betroffenen
metropolen madrid und barcelona aber
bleiben die ausgangssperren bestehen
in belgien haben wieder alle geschäfte
geöffnet wenn auch unter strengen
vorschriften so heißt es unter anderem
abstand halten
ein mund nasen schutz ist pflicht auch
der britische premier boris johnson
johnson hat vorsichtige lockerungen der
strengen coroner regeln angekündigt und
das obwohl sich das virus in
großbritannien weiter rasch ausbreitet
mehr als 220.000 fälle sind durch tests
bestätigt seit sechs wochen kommen
täglich mehr als 3000 dazu und nennen es
in europa starben mehr menschen in
verbindung mit coop 19 bislang mehr als
32.000 ja sie nie allein berichtete
es hatte dann doch eine erklärung
bedurft boris johnsons gestern
verkündete fahrplan aus der korona krise
blieb zu vage machte es sinn mit einem
50 seiten papier und diesen
erläuterungen im parlament heute
nachzulegen
zu diesem zeitpunkt können wir nicht
weiter gehen als einige vorsichtige
veränderungen unserer maßnahmen
vorzunehmen
eine verschiebung im schwerpunkt unserer
bemühung die diese woche beginnen kann
wirken beginnen
doch der opposition dass auch das noch
zu wenig das land in diesen zeiten
braucht ist
klarheit und sicherheit moment ist dies
mangelware
das problem scheint mir zu sein dass der
premierminister gestern seine
ankündigung machte bevor der plan
überhaupt fertig geschrieben war pure
play music hall ist fein wald im kern
sieht der plan der regierung folgendes
vor mehr als eine sportliche betätigung
draußen pro tag ist nun möglich wer kann
wird ermutigt zur arbeit zu gehen
schulen öffnen schrittweise ab juni
restaurants und pubs vielleicht ab juli
und wer mit dem flugzeug und nicht aus
frankreich oder irland einreist soll
demnächst 14 tage in quarantäne müssen
dass logan der regierung lautet nun
nicht mehr bleibt zu hause und schütze
das gesundheitswesen sondern bleibt
wachsam alte das virus unter kontrolle
dettl eben doch schottland wales und
nordirland ziehen da nicht mit für die
einen sind johnsons pläne zu gefährlich
anderen gehen sie nicht weit genug
mehr war letztlich nicht zu erwarten
dazu ist großbritannien in allem zu sehr
hinterher und in der toten statistik zu
weit vorne
was mache ich bloß mit den kindern diese
frage treibt zurzeit alle eltern um erst
recht wenn sie arbeiten müssen in
mecklenburg vorpommern dürfen eltern
seit heute ihre kinder wieder zu
tagesmüttern bringen
auch weil das land weniger
neuinfektionen hat heute gerade mal ein
ganz unproblematisch scheint die öffnung
allerdings nicht wie anja casinos
berichtet ganz einfach ist es nicht für
die kleinen
nach knapp zwei monaten zu hause geht es
zurück zu ihrer tagesmutter in schwerin
morgens kommen die kinder im
viertelstundentakt eltern sollen sich
bei der abgabe nicht mehr begegnen
der abschied auch für die mütter schwer
diese zeit mit mama ist intensive gerade
war auch sehr schön aber jetzt ist es
auch so gut wie es ist und ich freue
mich auch wieder ein bisschen in meinem
alltag anzukommen
händewaschen unter aufsicht häufigeres
putzen in der kinder wohnung es ist eine
öffnung unter strengen auflagen
beim schlafen die betten sollen an
enthalt meter auseinander stehen das
macht sich sehr schwierig einige
kindertagespflegepersonen haben gar
nicht die räumliche möglichkeit in kaum
einem anderen bundesland waren vor der
korona krise so viele kleinkinder in
betreuung wie im nordosten
viele eltern werden wieder in
gastronomie und tourismus gebraucht und
so macht die politik bei den kleinsten
abstriche von der überall geforderten
distanz das bei kindern anderthalb meter
abstand einhalten schwierig ist das ist
selbstverständlich deswegen müssen wir
da bei der hygiene auf andere dinge wert
legen händewaschen keine
gruppenübergreifende arbeit die kinder
müssen also unter sich bleiben
in einer woche sollen in mecklenburg
vorpommern auch kita vorschulkinder
wieder betreut werden dass das unter den
hohen auflagen funktionieren kann
bezweifeln viele träger und fordern
nachbesserungen von der landespolitik
und welche kinder nahmen in den nächsten
jahren am häufigsten zu hören sein
werden das wissen wir jetzt auch die
beliebtesten babynamen 2009 10 waren
nämlich hanna und noah bei den mädchen
dicht gefolgt von emma und mia bei den
jungs kamen ben und paul auf platz zwei
und drei
das hat die gesellschaft für deutsche
sprache aus daten der standesämter
ausgewertet und dabei festgestellt
kindernamen werden in deutschland immer
kürzer und weicher einen namen habe ich
noch der bei neugeborenen so gar keine
rolle spielt mamertus der gallische
bischof ist der erste der sogenannten
eisheiligen
er hat seinem titel alle ehre gemacht im
harz sogar mit schnee und eis und auch
sonst fast überall mit deutlich
niedrigeren temperaturen und wann der
winter spuk vorbei ist sagt leicht katja
hornuf an marietta slomka begrüßt sie um
viertel vor zehn im heute-journal hier
übernimmt morgen christian sievers danke
für ihr interesse
ich wünsche ihnen noch eine gute woche
und sagt auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
meine damen und herren gestern
nachmittag lagen die temperaturen am
oberrhein noch bei 27 grad und heute
vormittag dann nur noch bei vier grad
dahinter steckte eine kaltfront und die
ist heute im laufe des tages langsam
weiter richtung südosten gezogen es gab
auch kräftige gewitter und starkregen
und in diesem kaltfront band da hat es
doch sehr viel geregnet und bis
mitternacht werden hier in dieser region
von der lausitz bis zum oberrhein so 20
bis 35 liter innerhalb von nur 24
stunden zusammenkommen
das ist in der region dann mehr als im
ganzen monat april gefallen ist und auch
jetzt in der nacht fällt noch schnee
regen der zieht sich immer weiter
richtung südosten zurück gefährlich
glatt kann es in den mittelgebirgen
werden denn da fallen einige zentimeter
neuschnee oberhalb von 6 700 meter aber
auch wenn die wolken abgezogen sind kann
es glatt sein nämlich durch
überfrierende nässe
denn für bodenfrost reicht es überall in
deutschland mit nur zwei ausnahmen hier
am östlichen alpenrand und auch an der
nordsee die temperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 9 grad in nordfriesland oder
auch im nordhessischen bergland und 15
grad am oberrhein und an den alpen sind
die wolken etwas dichter sonst wird es
freundlich über norddeutschland ziehen
einige regenschauer hinweg und ganz
ähnlich geht es in den nächsten tagen
auch weiter schönen abend noch